The strangest thing about Eli's trip into America is not that he was smuggled part way from Guatemala in a tanker truck-- one of those huge trucks that usually carries fuel-- sealed in with 100 people, no windows or light, people fainting as the air got stale. And the strangest thing about Eli's trip into America was not that after they crossed the border at the Rio Grande, they were lost in the desert for 36 hours, and he had to drink his own urine to survive.
关于Eli来美国的旅程，最奇怪的不是他从危地马拉出发时被藏在油罐车里偷渡入境——就是那种通常用来运油的巨大卡车，里面密封了100个人，没有窗户，没有光，随着空气变得浑浊，人们纷纷昏倒。Eli来美旅程中最奇怪的也不是他在跨越格兰德河边境后，在沙漠里迷路了36个小时，不得不靠喝自己的尿液活下来。
Yeah, it tasted a little salty. That's it. Yeah. You don't taste it. You just drink it. You just swallow it. It left a little aftertaste, but it kept me alive.
嗯，尝起来有点咸。就这样。没错。你根本不会去品尝它。你只是喝下去。你只是把它吞了。虽然留下了一点余味，但它让我活了下来。
No, the strangest thing about Eli's trip into America is that the day he gets to Chicago, after a month on the road, nearly dying twice, 24 hours after he gets to his final destination, he goes to work washing dishes where a friend of his works at Charlie Trotters, one of the most expensive and exclusive restaurants in the country, where you pay over $100 a person, and they bring you whatever the menu happens to be that day.
不，Eli来美的旅程中最奇怪的是，他抵达芝加哥的那天，经过一个月的路途，两次死里逃生，在他到达最终目的地的24小时后，他去了一家朋友工作的餐馆洗碗，那是Charlie Trotters，全国最昂贵、最顶级的餐厅之一，每人消费超过100美元，而且他们会直接端上当天刚好做的菜。
Well, I felt like a stranger in a strange world, totally different of what I was used to. Like let's say dish machine. What the hell did I know about dish machine? The kitchen well-equipped with compartments and coolers, and then walking into the dining room and the tablecloths white and neat.
嗯，我感觉自己像个陌生世界里的异乡人，一切都和我习惯的完全不同。比如洗碗机。我哪知道什么洗碗机啊？厨房里设备齐全，有储物间和冷却器，然后走进餐厅，餐桌上铺着整洁的白色桌布。
That's the place where I seen the biggest wine glasses, a wine glass that could fit a bottle of wine. I remember breaking one of these big glasses. When I was told that they were over $100 each, I just went like, wow.
那是我见过最大的葡萄酒杯的地方，一个能装下一整瓶酒的酒杯。我记得打破了其中一个大杯子。当有人告诉我它们每个值100多美元时，我心想，哇。
Then there's the wine themselves. Lots of people would spend $1,000 for a meal. Coming from the countryside in Guatemala, where he only needed $200 a month to maintain his home and feed his family, it was hard to comprehend.
还有那些酒。很多人一顿饭就能花掉1000美元。对于来自危地马拉农村的他来说，他每个月只需要200美元就能维持家庭生计，这简直难以理解。
There was these wild nights, I threw away a lot of food and I thought of how many people in my country could use it. You know, how much food and money was wasted. It was amazing. It's still amazing.
当时有那些疯狂的夜晚，我扔掉了很多食物，我想着在我家乡有多少人能用得上这些。你知道，有多少食物和金钱被浪费了。这太惊人了。现在依然让人震惊。
But I think that's just the way people live in this country and that might be what keeps them so blind about the rest of the world. How starving are people, you know, in parts of the planet. I'm not saying they're bad. It's just the way they live here.
但我认为这就是这个国家的人们生活的方式，而这或许就是让他们对世界其他地方视而不见的原因。你知道，这个星球上还有多少人在忍饥挨饿。我不是说他们坏。这只是他们在这里的生活方式而已。
If you go someplace new, you're a stranger in a strange land, you try to make sense of everything around you. And you come to conclusions that are probably different than the things that people who live there think every day. Well, today on our radio program, we have stories of people in that very situation. You're listening to This American Life from WBEZ Chicago, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
如果你去了一个陌生的地方，你就是异乡里的异客，你会试着去解读周围的一切。你会得出一些结论，这些结论可能和你当地人每天所想的完全不同。今天在我们的广播节目中，我们要讲述的就是处于这种境地的人们的故事。你现在收听的是WBEZ芝加哥制作的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际传播。我是Ira Glass。
Act One of our show today, a man tries to reinvent tourism-- yes, tourism-- but he runs into a few snags once he gets to Africa. Act Two, Johnny, Get Your Mouse. You've probably heard about these American soldiers who are blogging from the war in Iraq, but chances are you've never actually taken the time to read many of these blogs. Well, we have done that work for you and have chosen some excerpts. Stories of strangers in a strange land filled with guns and land mines and IEDs. Very different stories from what you get on the news. Stay with us.
节目的第一幕，一个人试图重塑旅游业——没错，是旅游业——但他到了非洲后遇到了一些障碍。第二幕，约翰尼，去抓你的鼠标。你可能听说过那些在伊拉克战争中写博客的美国士兵，但你很可能从未花时间去读过这些博客。好吧，我们为你做了这项工作，并挑选了一些摘录。这是一个充满枪支、地雷和简易爆炸装置的陌生土地上的异乡人的故事。这与你在新闻中看到的故事截然不同。请继续收听。
Act One, Not Just Tourists, Tourists Who Care. A guy named Chris Tenove came into our studio to talk about his idea to change the face of tourism and to tell the story of his international-- I don't even know the word for this-- the international beta test, I guess, that he did of his idea.
第一幕，不只是游客，是有爱心的游客。一个叫Chris Tenove的人来到我们的演播室，讲述他改变旅游业面貌的想法，并分享了他为这个构想所做的国际测试——我甚至不知道该怎么称呼这个——我想，那应该是一次国际性的Beta测试。
But before we get into any of that, you should understand a little bit about the kind of person that Chris Tenove is, and the kinds of big ideas that kick around in his head.
但在我们深入探讨之前，你应该稍微了解一下Chris Tenove是什么样的人，以及他脑子里总是在酝酿些什么样的宏大想法。
I guess from time to time I've tried to come up with these sort of abstract plans on how to save the world. And I've done this a few times.
我想我不时会构思出一些关于如何拯救世界的抽象计划。我做过好几次了。
There was at one point I had this idea-- I mean, this is a bit of a tangent. I had this idea that gay men in America who can't legally marry each other could go to Burma and marry women there, grant them citizenship, and through that overthrow the Burmese government. And that's a horrible idea for a lot of different reasons--
有一次我有个想法——我的意思是，这有点跑题了。我当时想，美国那些不能合法结婚的男同性恋者可以去缅甸，和那里的女性结婚，授予她们公民身份，以此推翻缅甸政府。由于很多不同的原因，这真是个糟糕的主意——
Right.
对。
--I think. Actually, I was smart enough to more or less-- I've more or less kept it to myself.
——我想是吧。其实，我足够聪明，没怎么说出来——我基本上把它藏在心里了。
His idea to remake international tourism is another matter. Chris came up with the idea after a dinner with some family friends who had just gotten back from New Zealand.
他重塑国际旅游业的想法则是另一回事。Chris是在和一些刚从新西兰回来的家庭朋友吃过晚饭后产生的这个想法。
These are people who, looked at in a certain way, could be seen as kind of obnoxious. These are the kind of people who want that authentic experience wherever they travel. In New Zealand they went to where farmers shear sheep. When they visited Thailand, they visited hill tribe villages in Thailand.
从某种角度看，这些人可能会被认为有点招人烦。他们是那种无论去哪旅游都想要“地道体验”的人。在新西兰，他们去看农民剪羊毛。去泰国时，他们去拜访那里的部落村庄。
But Chris thought, you know, these people are interested in the world, and if somebody could just harness that energy, they could actually do a lot of good.
但Chris心想，你知道，这些人对世界感兴趣，如果有人能善加利用这种能量，他们实际上可以做很多好事。
I guess I really fundamentally believe that there's a lot of good-hearted people with a fair amount of disposable income, who would be willing to really engage financially and emotionally with communities that are impoverished. And I thought, how do you get people to engage? And I thought travel. And maybe we can get them there, get them engaged, and do something useful, do something philanthropic.
我想我从根本上相信，有很多好心人拥有相当可观的可支配收入，他们愿意在经济和情感上真正地与那些贫困社区建立联系。我想，怎么才能让人们参与进来呢？我想到的是旅行。也许我们可以把他们带到那里，让他们参与进来，做点有用的事，做点慈善。
So you had this idea that people could go over to other countries and give away money? Is that the idea? What would they do once they were there?
所以你的想法是人们可以去其他国家捐钱？这就是你的想法吗？他们到了那里之后会做什么？
Well, all right. Let's say a small group of people would go to a country like Niger, and they would be taken to a village. And they would spend, let's say, a week there getting to know people, seeing what life is like, and developing a relationship or bond with the people there.
好吧，是这样的。比方说，一小群人去尼日尔这样的国家，然后被带到一个村庄。他们会在那里待上一周，了解当地人，看看他们的生活是什么样的，并与当地人建立起某种关系或纽带。
And then when it's time to go, they would leave a sizable enough amount of money to do some good there. I mean, I bet like $500 would pay for building a school, or it would pay for anti-malarial medications for a year for the village. And then they'd go home, and they'd have this continuing bond with the people there.
等到要离开时，他们会留下一笔相当可观的钱，在那里做些好事。我是说，我打赌500美元就能建一所学校，或者能支付整个村庄一年的抗疟疾药物费用。然后他们回家，并与那里的人们保持这种持续的纽带。
Now in fact, there already exists something like this, a small movement that goes under various names-- travelers' philanthropy, volunteer tourism, altruistic travel-- where you go to the places, and maybe you don't get to know the people there quite as well as Chris envisions. Maybe you're not in places quite so desperately off the beaten path, but you visit, you see poverty, and after which you donate some money.
事实上，这种模式已经存在了，这是一个以各种名目运作的小型运动——旅行者慈善、志愿旅游、利他旅行——你去了那些地方，也许你无法像Chris所设想的那样深入了解当地人。也许你不在那种极其偏僻的地方，但你确实去参观了，看到了贫困，然后捐了一些钱。
Chris didn't know about any of that, though, and he didn't know anybody had ever tried to figure out what was right or wrong about his idea. And so he started talking to experts, aid workers, about this thing that he decided to call philanthropy tourism. None of them had ever heard about the idea either.
不过，Chris并不知道这些，也不知道有没有人尝试过评估他的想法是对是错。于是他开始咨询专家和援助人员，谈论这个他决定称之为“慈善旅游”的东西。他们以前也没听过这种想法。
Now Chris is a freelance reporter for the Canadian Broadcasting Corporation. He travels quite a bit to southeast Asia, Cambodia, Thailand. And as fate had it, Chris actually was headed out to one of the poorest countries in the world, Sierra Leone, for his job.
Chris是加拿大广播公司的自由记者。他经常去东南亚，比如柬埔寨和泰国。命运使然，Chris当时正好要为工作前往世界上最贫穷的国家之一：塞拉利昂。
Step one was talking to a few aid workers, and they generally told me it wasn't a great idea. I mean, I was told it was a sickening idea by some. And other people thought it was a pretty good idea. Most people had reservations.
第一步是和几位援助人员谈谈，他们普遍告诉我这不是个好主意。我是说，有些人甚至告诉我这听起来很恶心。其他人则觉得这是个不错的主意。大多数人持保留意见。
Yeah, we have a clip of a tape that you made at the time. This is Anthony Lawson, a British aid worker for Action for Children in Conflict. Is that it?
是的，我们有一段你当时录下的片段。这是Anthony Lawson，英国“儿童冲突行动”组织的援助人员。是这个组织吗？
Yep.
对。
And here's what she had to say when you ran your idea by her.
当你把你的想法告诉她时，她是这么说的。
I think those who've done aid work for any length of time would probably be somewhat disturbed by that idea.
我想那些长期从事援助工作的人会对这个想法感到不安。
Why?
为什么？
Because you'd then be turning the people who are the beneficiaries of the aid work into kind of gawking targets for tourists, which is completely unethical.
因为你把那些援助的受益者变成了游客猎奇的目标，这在伦理上是完全错误的。
What do you think of that?
你对此怎么看？
Hey, it's a really valid criticism. I guess the issue that maybe bothered me the most was this image that it would be wealthy North Americans coming and just tossing out money like bread crumbs to pigeons or something, and that you'd get these kicks helping them, and then you'd go back to life. That image of it is-- I mean, I find it repugnant.
嘿，这确实是一个非常有效的批评。我想最困扰我的问题是，这会给人一种形象：富裕的北美人过来，像给鸽子撒面包屑一样随手撒钱，然后从中获得某种快感，接着就回去继续过自己的生活。那个画面——我是说，我觉得这很令人作呕。
But this did not deter Chris. Sure, these were valid concerns, he thought. But the impact that this could have on people's lives could be so great, he hoped there just could be some way to do it reasonably, without the gawking, without the exploitation.
但这并没有阻止Chris。他觉得，这确实是有效的担忧。但如果能以合理的方式做到这一点，没有猎奇，没有剥削，这对人们生活的影响可能会非常巨大。
And so, like a doctor in a science fiction movie who develops an experimental serum and, worried that it is too dangerous to try out the serum on anybody else, injects it into his own veins first, Chris decided to try out philanthropy tourism himself. He would do himself under the crucible.
所以，就像科幻电影里开发出实验血清的医生，担心在别人身上试验太危险，于是先把它注射到自己血管里一样，Chris决定亲自尝试一下慈善旅游。他要让自己接受考验。
Like I said, he was in Sierra Leone anyway. He'd go to a poor village himself, meet the people, and donate some money to see if it could possibly be done without all the pitfalls and problems. It was kind of ad hoc.
正如我所说，他反正是要去塞拉利昂。他自己去了一个贫穷的村庄，结识当地人，并捐了一些钱，看看这是否能在没有所有这些陷阱和问题的情况下实现。这有点像临时起意。
Planning? You know, I didn't do much planning. I'd planned to plan at some point, but then I found myself in a car going to this isolated village called Tombodu, and we were about to get there, and I just thought, well, let's give it a shot.
计划？你知道，我没做太多计划。我本来打算之后再计划的，但后来发现自己已经在去一个叫Tombodu的偏远村庄的车上了，快到的时候，我心想，好吧，尝试一下吧。
You mean you were going to the village to do interviewing for your reporting?
你是说你去村庄是为了做采访报道？
Yeah. Yeah, we were literally like a few hundred meters out of this village, and I was traveling with the chief's nephew, and I said, when we get to the village, I'd like to talk to the elders, because I'd like to pay for someone in the village who needs a medical operation. And he said, what? Are you sure? And I said, yeah. And he said, OK, well, we'll talk to the elders.
对。对，我们离村庄真的只有几百米远了，我和酋长的侄子在一起，我说，我们到村子后，我想和长老谈谈，因为我想为一个村里需要手术的人支付费用。他说，什么？你确定吗？我说，是。他说，好吧，那我们跟长老谈谈。
OK, so you go there and what happens when you're brought before the elders of a small village?
好吧，所以你去了那里，当被带到小村庄的长老面前时发生了什么？
It wasn't very formal. The chief's nephew knew who to look for, and we stopped by a couple houses and actually just picked the guys up, and we had this little conference in the back of the car. And they said, well, we know the guy. We know the guy. We'll get him for you.
并不怎么正式。酋长的侄子知道该找谁，我们在几间房子旁停下来，直接把人接上，我们在车后座开了个小会。他们说，嗯，我们认识那个人。我们知道是谁。我们会把他带给你。
And what was his medical ailment that he needed an operation on?
他需要做手术的医疗问题是什么？
Well, it had something to do with an infected and torn scrotum that had been bothering him for a long time, for years. And when I later met him, I could see he was having great difficulty walking. And so I just said, well, they know who needs the operation, so this is it.
嗯，这与他感染且撕裂的阴囊有关，这已经困扰他很长时间了，好几年了。我后来见到他时，能看出他走路非常困难。所以我直接说，既然他们知道谁需要手术，那就定他了。
Did you have any sense of if he was trying to get the money together for an operation?
你知道他是否正在为手术筹钱吗？
Yeah, well, he told me that that morning he'd gone with his younger brother on the trip into a nearby town. And he'd gone to the doctors, and they'd said, this is what it is, and they wrote out how much it would cost to pay for an operation, which was the whopping sum of $150. And this was going to take, he figured, about a year long fundraising to get that kind of money together.
是的，他告诉我，那天早上他和弟弟去附近的镇上走了一趟。他去了医生那里，医生告诉了他病情，并写下了手术费用，总共是150美元。他计算过，这笔钱可能需要筹集一年。
And so I came, literally, an hour after he returned to the village. And so he told me later, he said, heaven sent you to me. I know you're an angel.
所以我简直是在他回到村子一小时后就出现了。他后来对我说，是天堂把你派到我身边的。我知道你是天使。
$150? It just seems like so little.
150美元？这看起来太少了。
Yeah. It's a poor country and Tombodu is a poor village in Sierra Leone.
是的。那是个贫穷的国家，Tombodu是塞拉利昂一个贫穷的村庄。
Now I understand you then made a speech to the village, and we have a recording of that that you made. And can you just tell me, what is the setting? Who was there? Where are you? Are you just standing out in the open?
我听说你后来对村子发表了演讲，我们有你录下的录音。你能告诉我，当时的情景吗？谁在场？你在哪里？你只是站在空地上吗？
As I'd been walking around the village, there'd been more and more people gathering around. So there were 10 and then 20, and then, I think, there was about 50 people by then. And we were going to be driving out of town with this fellow, and, in fact, the chief's nephew had said, you know, we can't just toss him in the car and drive off. You've got to say something to explain it.
当我走遍村子时，聚集的人越来越多。一开始是10个人，然后是20个人，到那时我想大概有50个人了。我们本来要带着那个人开车离开，事实上，酋长的侄子说过，你不能直接把他扔进车里就开走。你得说点什么来解释一下。
OK. Here's a recording of it.
好的。这是录音。
Hello, everyone. My name is Chris. I'm from Canada.
大家好。我的名字叫Chris。我来自加拿大。
[SPEAKING KRIO]
[克里奥语发言]
Before I left Canada,
在我离开加拿大之前，
[SPEAKING KRIO]
[克里奥语发言]
I talked to some of my relatives, and I told them I was coming to Sierra Leone.
我跟一些亲戚谈过，告诉他们我要来塞拉利昂。
[SPEAKING KRIO]
[克里奥语发言]
And I asked them if they could give me a little bit of money to help someone.
我问他们能不能给我一点钱来帮助别人。
Now I'm just going to stop the tape right there before we go further. Is that true?
现在我要在继续之前暂停一下录音。那是真的吗？
You mean, that I'd asked relatives to pitch in?
你是说，我问亲戚们出钱的事？
Yes.
对。
Yeah.
是的。
Really? Strictly speaking true?
真的吗？严格来说是真的吗？
It was probably-- what I was spending was, I don't know, half mine and half of family members. But you know what? I was really glad to be able to say that.
这大概是——我花的钱，不知道，一半是我自己的，一半是家人的。但你知道吗？我真的很高兴能这么说。
I mean, it feels weird to say, hey, look, I'm giving this money for these people. I liked to be able to say this isn't me doing something. It's family members. I'm just sort of an instrument.
我的意思是，说“嘿，看，我在给这些人捐钱”感觉很奇怪。我喜欢能够说这不是我自己在做什么。这是家人们的心意。我只是某种工具。
Let me play a little more tape.
让我再多放一点录音。
So this is why I'm taking this man from your village to the doctor.
所以这就是为什么我要带你们村里的这个人去看医生。
[SPEAKING KRIO]
[克里奥语发言]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
And so then they break into applause, and you feel--
然后他们开始鼓掌，你感觉——
Yeah, that was my Angelina Jolie moment. On the one hand, it was a little bit giddy. It's nice to have all these people cheering for something you've decided to do. But on the other hand, I really did feel like a big fraud. I mean, the 50 people like, literally, started cheering, and I thought, this is $150 that I'm spending, but it seems like there's way too much veneration, way too much excitement, I mean.
是的，那就是我的安吉丽娜·朱莉时刻。一方面，有点飘飘然。有人为你决定做的事欢呼感觉不错。但另一方面，我确实感觉自己像个大骗子。我是说，那50个人真的开始欢呼了，而我想，我花的不过是150美元，但这看起来得到的尊崇和兴奋太多了，我的意思是。
Was there a part of you which wanted to say to them, no, no, no. You don't understand. This really isn't very much for me.
你有没有想过对他们说，不，不，不。你们不明白。这对我不算什么。
Yeah. Yeah, right. Like, don't get so excited. Yeah, that would have been a weird thing to say.
是的。没错。就像，别这么兴奋。是的，说那种话会很奇怪。
Yeah.
对。
But also I was told-- another thing that aid workers and also the chief's nephew brought up is that there's a real problem that people come to expect every foreigner is going to give a lot of money. The aid workers had coached me, don't encourage this culture of dependency. Make sure to say that not every foreigner is going to come along with money and do something like this.
但我也被告知——援助人员和酋长的侄子提到的另一件事是，这确实有一个问题，人们开始期望每个外国人都会给很多钱。援助人员曾指导我，不要鼓励这种依赖文化。一定要说清楚，不是每个外国人过来都会带着钱做这样的事。
I just want to say something very clear.
我只想说得非常清楚。
[SPEAKING KRIO]
[克里奥语发言]
Please don't expect every white person who comes to do this.
请不要指望每个来这里的人都会这么做。
[SPEAKING KRIO]
[克里奥语发言]
And there are a lot of NGOs now and organizations in Sierra Leone.
现在塞拉利昂有很多非政府组织和机构。
[SPEAKING KRIO]
[克里奥语发言]
And one day most of them, they're going to slowly leave.
总有一天他们中的大多数会慢慢离开。
Yeah, what the hell am I talking about there? I mean, it's true the UN is hugely invested in Sierra Leone right now after the end of the civil war and they are going to start pulling out. But, I don't know, it just seems sort of arrogant to say-- to be kind of wagging my finger and saying, you guys have got to establish your own health care system. You know, you can't expect foreigners to do it.
是的，我在那里胡说什么呢？我的意思是，联合国在内战结束后确实在塞拉利昂投入巨大，他们确实会开始撤出。但是，我不知道，说这种话似乎很傲慢——就像我在摇着手指说，你们这些家伙得建立自己的医疗体系。你们知道，不能指望外国人来做这件事。
Yeah.
对。
After that speech and when we got into the car and started bouncing our way back to the nearby town, I finally got the chance to start talking to this man and that was when things really started to feel right.
那次演讲之后，当我们上车开始颠簸着往附近城镇回赶时，我终于有机会开始和那个人交谈了，那时候事情才真正开始感觉对了。
And actually, we ended up sitting together for a couple hours and just chatting. And he told me about his life, really, and about his grandchildren and about the day he found a diamond in the pits nearby and was able to build this nice house that later got burned down by the rebels.
实际上，我们坐在一起聊了几个小时。他真的告诉我关于他的生活，关于他的孙子孙女，关于他曾在附近的矿坑里发现了一颗钻石，并因此建起了那座后来被叛军烧毁的好房子。
You know, talking about his grandchildren and how he wasn't going to be a boring old man anymore. He said once he had this operation, he'd be able to garden again and walk around. And so, it was quite touching. It was nice to have gotten to know him over that afternoon and early evening.
你知道，谈论他的孙辈，谈论他不想再做一个无聊的老人了。他说一旦做了手术，他就能再次耕种和行走了。所以，这很动人。在那天下午和傍晚时分了解他，感觉很好。
And so his first field test turned out exactly how Chris had hoped it would. And as he traveled, he even met some people in Sierra Leone who saw his vision, who got really excited about the idea of philanthropy tourism.
所以他的第一次实地测试结果正如Chris所希望的那样。在他旅行时，他甚至在塞拉利昂遇到了一些理解他愿景的人，他们对慈善旅游的想法感到非常兴奋。
And there was one woman who already was trying to think of how to get people to visit this little hippo preserve, this baby-- no, what was it? Miniature hippo preserve in Sierra Leone. And she was working out how much it would cost.
有一位女士已经在考虑如何让人来参观这个小河马保护区，是婴儿——不，那是什么？塞拉利昂的微型河马保护区。她正在计算这需要多少钱。
What are you talking about? I feel like she's sitting on gold. She has miniature baby hippos?
你在说什么？我觉得她坐拥金矿。她有微型小河马？
Yeah.
是的。
And she can't get Westerners to come and give money? Like, that's the easiest sell I've ever heard. She basically is sitting on like wild, African, baby, miniature, baby African hippo puppies, right? Like, that's what we're talking about here.
而她找不到西方人过来捐款？这简直是我听过最容易的生意了。她基本上是在养野生、非洲、婴儿、微型、非洲河马宝宝，对吧？那是我们在说的东西吗？
Yeah. Well, the problem is it's in Sierra Leone, the land of the child soldiers and amputation squads. So it's not-- Sierra Leone is not an easy tourism sell.
是的。好吧，问题是它在塞拉利昂，那是童兵和截肢小队的土地。所以这不是一个容易卖出的旅游项目。
It's actually such a tough tourism sell, Chris thought, that it would be prudent to do a second trial of his experiment. After all, it's not really science if you can't replicate your results. He heard about a nonprofit organization called Gracelands that had a good reputation for helping people. He thought maybe he'd try there.
Chris心想，这实际上是一个如此艰难的旅游卖点，以至于谨慎地进行第二次实验是明智的。毕竟，如果不能复现结果，那就不叫科学。他听说了一个叫“格雷斯兰”的非营利组织，该组织以帮助人们而声誉良好。他想也许可以在那里试试。
It's an organization for traumatized young women. Most of them were bush brides, which meant during the civil war, rebel groups would've captured them in their village and taken them off. And a lot of them would have been gang raped and forced to serve this rebel group in these sort of marriages.
这是一个为受创伤年轻女性设立的组织。她们大多数是“丛林新娘”，这意味着在内战期间，叛军在她们的村庄抓走了她们。她们中很多人遭到了轮奸，并被迫在某种婚姻中服务于叛军。
I'd also found out that there was a young woman there who needed an operation. And so, I was going to give them money for this operation to the organization, but I thought, you know, I'd spend an afternoon there.
我还发现那里有一个年轻女性需要手术。所以，我本来打算捐钱给这个组织进行手术，但我心想，我应该在那里待一下午。
You just wanted to get to know them a little bit.
你只是想多了解她们一点。
Yeah. And I didn't even plan on getting to know this one woman whose operation I was paying for in particular. I thought, we'll just hangout and we'll have this same sort of thing that I had with the gentleman in the other village.
对。我甚至没打算特别去了解那个我为其支付手术费的女性。我想，我们只是聚在一起，就像我和另一个村庄的那位先生一样。
But it didn't quite happen that way. When I got there, you know, we started talking, and then the young women there would start to tell me exactly what had happened to them.
但这并没有发生。当我到那里时，我们开始交谈，然后那里的年轻女性就开始告诉我到底发生了什么。
You mean, because you asked or just because you were this foreigner who was in there and it seemed like the thing to do?
你是说，因为你问了，还是因为你这个外国人在这里，看起来就应该这样做？
Well, I mean, I would ask a question like, where are you from or something like that. And they would describe being captured by the rebels and they'd talk about the difficult straits they were in now. And I kind of got the feeling that these young women thought, here's someone who can provide help, and so we've got to show to him we really need it.
好吧，我的意思是，我会问一个类似“你来自哪里”的问题。然后她们就会描述被叛军俘虏的经历，讲述她们现在处于何种困境。我有一种感觉，这些年轻女性心想，这里有人能提供帮助，所以我们必须向他展示我们确实很需要它。
And so, even though it was sort of uncomfortable, they would start to describe these painful incidents. And, in fact, I don't even really know how this happened-- I mean, why the conversations took that turn, but it happened again and again. I just felt horrible.
所以，尽管这让人有点不舒服，她们还是开始描述那些痛苦的经历。事实上，我甚至不知道这是怎么发生的——我的意思是，为什么对话会变成那样，但这却一次又一次地发生。我感觉糟透了。
Now we have a recording of you with some of these women, and I have to say, it seems so painful. I'm not sure I even want to put it on the radio, just because it feels-- like your heart goes out to these women who just start crying when they start talking to you about this.
现在我们有你和这些女性谈话的录音，我必须说，这看起来太痛苦了。我不确定我甚至想在广播里放这个，因为它让人感觉——当她们开始向你倾诉这些时，你会对这些开始哭泣的女性深感同情。
And I wonder, at the end of that experience did you feel like, OK, well, that's it. I guess this isn't such a great idea. Like, how did you feel at the end of that?
我想知道，在经历结束时你是否感觉，好吧，就到这吧。我想这不是个好主意。在那次经历结束时你的感觉如何？
Yeah. I felt exploitative, you know, that I was coming there to-- OK, I was going to give some money, but I was also going to enjoy their company and maybe even feel good about what I was doing. And then instead of it being pleasurable for everyone it turned into what was really these heart wringing catalysts for grief while I was there.
是的。我感到在剥削，你知道，我来到这里——好吧，我是要捐一些钱，但我也想享受她们的陪伴，甚至可能对我所做的事情感觉良好。结果，这并没有让每个人都感到愉快，反而变成了那种揪心的悲伤催化剂。
And so, I kind of think that that one was a mistake. But, ultimately, even though the second time didn't work out that well, I still think it was a good idea for me, because it just really convinced me that you can engage and with these small amounts of money, you can really do something useful. I think it's absurd how easy it is and that it's not being done.
所以，我确实认为那一次是一个错误。但最终，尽管第二次不太顺利，我仍然认为这对我是个好主意，因为它确实让我坚信，你可以参与进来，用这些少量的钱，你真的可以做一些有用的事。我认为这种做法如此简单却没人去做，简直荒谬。
But you say it's so easy, but when you talked to that woman, it seemed like it was incredibly painful for her.
但你说这很容易，可当你和那个女人交谈时，看起来这对她来说极其痛苦。
Yeah. I guess what I think was the easy part in that situation, it was very easy to give. It was like $120 for this operation, which is not that much money and you can change someone's life. That's the easy part. The really difficult part is these relationships.
是的。我想在那种情况下，我认为容易的部分是，捐钱非常容易。手术费用大约是120美元，这不是很多钱，却能改变某人的一生。那是容易的部分。真正困难的部分是这些关系。
I wonder if the thing that makes it so tough is the fact that you're trying to get something back from it. Do you know what I mean? Like, when you talk about it, you say, you thought you'd enjoy their company. You thought that you'd have an experience that would make you feel good about what you're doing, and I wonder if the nature of this kind of act is that you have to do it not expecting anything back.
我想知道，让这事变得如此艰难的是不是因为你想从中得到回报？你明白我的意思吗？就像你说的那样，你说你以为你会享受她们的陪伴。你以为你会获得一段让自己对所做之事感觉良好的经历，我怀疑这种行为的本质是，你必须在不期待任何回报的情况下去做。
Yeah. I think that's true. I mean, and why do we have to have a good time when doing this? I just think it's because people need an inducement in order to do the right thing sometimes.
是的。我认为是真的。我的意思是，为什么我们做这件事时非得玩得开心呢？我只是觉得那是因为人们有时需要一种诱导才能做正确的事。
I know, but it's almost like you're trying to take people who don't want to be generous and say, well, there's something in it for you. And I feel like, in the end, maybe charity is really just going to be for the generous.
我知道，但这几乎像是你试图带走那些不想慷慨的人说，好吧，这事儿对你有好处。我觉得，归根结底，也许慈善真的只属于慷慨的人。
I think people will be more generous once they go and meet people and see what the situation is like. And so it's setting up that engagement. And this idea of philanthropy tourism, it's not for people who are already giving a lot of money to organizations. And I really believe that once people have actually seen what it's like, they will be generous.
我认为人们在真正见到当地人、看到情况是什么样之后会变得更慷慨。所以关键在于建立这种参与感。慈善旅游这个想法，不是为了那些已经向组织捐了很多钱的人。我坚信，一旦人们真正看到了实际情况，他们就会变得慷慨。
Chris Tenove. He still believes that somebody could get philanthropy tourism to work, somebody with organizational skills. He says that he'll still give to charity, but never again one-on-one in a village.
Chris Tenove。他仍然相信有人能把慈善旅游做成，某个具备组织能力的人。他说他仍然会向慈善机构捐款，但绝不会再一对一地深入村庄。
Coming up, some of the unpleasant dangers of being an American serviceman in Iraq-- IEDs, ambushes, subscriptions to Details magazine. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来的节目，作为驻伊拉克美国军人的一些令人不快和危险的经历——简易爆炸装置、伏击、订阅《Details》杂志。请稍候，来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Strangers in a Strange Land.
这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的主题是《异乡的陌生人》。
We've arrived at act two of our show. Act Two, Johnny, Get Your Mouse.
我们的节目进入了第二幕。第二幕，约翰尼，去抓你的鼠标。
Soldiers in Iraq are writing open diaries about their experience in that strange place on daily blogs that anybody can read on the internet. We now have excerpts of three of them. Many of the blogs that are out there very consciously try to counteract what soldiers consider the bias of the mainstream media.
在伊拉克的士兵正在互联网的每日博客上撰写关于他们在那个陌生地方经历的公开日记，任何人都可以阅读。我们现在有其中三篇的摘录。在那里发布的许多博客都有意识地试图反驳士兵们认为的主流媒体偏见。
These blogs tell stories of successes, schools built, kids who get health care. All of that is very common, but the blogs are much more than that. One of our producers, Amy O'Leary, has been reading dozens and dozens of the blogs trying to get a sense of what they're about and get an overview. Amy.
这些博客讲述了成功的故事，建成的学校，得到医疗的孩子。所有这些都很常见，但博客的内容远不止这些。我们的制片人之一，Amy O'Leary，一直在阅读成百上千篇博客，试图了解它们的内容并做一个综述。Amy。
Well, I would say about 20% of them are writing with, you know, an emphatic sort of political sensibility. By and large almost all of those are patriotic and conservative, and they are talking about the war and talking about their support for it.
嗯，我想大约20%的人写作时带有强调某种政治倾向的色彩。总的来说，几乎所有这些都是爱国和保守的，他们讨论战争，讨论对它的支持。
There's another 20% that are not really writing for anyone except friends or family. It's much more private.
另有20%的人并没有真的为任何人写作，只是为了朋友或家人。这更加私密。
So this is like in lieu of emailing a whole bunch of people. They just put it up there and the people who know them just look.
所以这就代替了发邮件给一大群人。他们只是把东西放上去，认识他们的人就去看看。
Right. And then the last group is the majority. And those blogs are really people who are trying to write about the war to explain it to people back in the States.
对。然后最后一组是多数。这些博客是真正试图通过写作来向国内的人解释战争的人。
What are they writing about?
他们在写什么？
How they pass the time. How they're doing. You know, a lot of it's counting down the days to come home. How the food is. You know, practical jokes they've played on the guys they're with. Pretty basic stuff. So, you know, if they go on missions, they talk about that.
他们如何打发时间。他们过得怎么样。你知道，很多是在倒计时回家的日子。食物怎么样。你知道，他们对战友开的恶作剧。非常基本的事情。所以，你知道，如果他们出任务，就会写那个。
A lot about Iraqi kids. Almost everybody talks about the kids they see in the street. There's so many pictures of soldiers helping kids, soldiers handing out candy and pens and pencils. They all seem to have a really strong affection and fondness for the kids in Iraq.
很多关于伊拉克孩子的内容。几乎每个人都在谈论他们在街上看到的孩子。有太多士兵帮助孩子的照片，士兵分发糖果、笔和纸。他们似乎对伊拉克的孩子都有非常强烈的感情和喜爱。
And so what's the picture that you get of the war after you read a lot of these that you might not have otherwise?
那么你在阅读了许多这些博客之后，对战争有了什么样的印象，是你原本可能不会有的？
There are so many people writing. There are so many blogs. There are so many people's lives who are encompassed by this war. And, you know, you might hear about an IED explosion. You might hear about, you know, a truck bomb or something, but then when you read about it over and over again, and you read-- like, almost anybody who's left the base has been hit by an IED. This is not, you know, a couple of isolated incidents. This is a fact of life for the people who are over there.
有太多人在写作。有太多的博客。有太多人的生活被这场战争所覆盖。而且，你知道，你可能会听说简易爆炸装置爆炸。你可能会听说卡车炸弹什么的，但当你一遍又一遍地读到它，当你读到——就像几乎任何离开基地的人都受到过简易爆炸装置的袭击。这不是几个孤立的事件。这是在那边生活的人们的生活事实。
OK. So now we're going to hear excerpts from a handful of different bloggers. And this first one is Captain Chuck Ziegenfuss. I should say that we have links to all of the URLs at our website, thisamericanlife.org. The URL for his blog is tcoverride.blogspot.com.
好的。现在我们要听听一些不同博主的摘录。第一个是Chuck Ziegenfuss上尉。我应该说，我们在我们的网站thisamericanlife.org上有所有网址的链接。他的博客地址是tcoverride.blogspot.com。
And he, on his blog, describes himself as an unashamedly patriotic American, 15 years in the army, the commander of Charlie Company 2 3 4 Armor in Iraq and at Fort Riley, Kansas. He had about 65 to 70 guys under him and 14 tanks. Here he is.
他在博客中描述自己是一个毫不掩饰的爱国美国人，在陆军服役了15年，是伊拉克和堪萨斯州赖利堡Charlie连2-3-4装甲部队的指挥官。他手下有65到70人，有14辆坦克。来听听他怎么说。
I had an interesting day. I went on another patrol, but this one got pretty interesting right off the bat. We were walking through a palm grove just looking around, and I looked about three feet to my right and saw a landmine.
我过了有趣的一天。我进行了另一次巡逻，但这次从一开始就变得相当有趣。我们走过一片棕榈树林，只是四处查看，我看向右边大约三英尺处，看到了一个地雷。
I immediately looked at my feet, not making the connection that if I had already stepped on a mine, I'd not have any feet. Well, we cordoned off the area and swept for more mines as some of the boys prepped it for demolition.
我立刻看向自己的脚，没联想到如果我已经踩到了地雷，我就不会有脚了。好吧，我们封锁了该区域并搜寻更多的地雷，同时一些伙计准备进行爆破。
About 30 minutes later, I was 50 yards away talking to one of my platoon sergeants, and I find another mine. This one is about 15 feet away under a piece of cinder block. Again, I look at my feet before saying, hey, isn't that a mine?
大约30分钟后，我在50码外和一个排军士谈话，我又发现了一个地雷。这个离我大约15英尺远，在一块煤渣砖下面。同样，我在说“嘿，那不是个地雷吗？”之前先看了看自己的脚。
We blew them both up and went about our business. The weird thing about all this was how normal it all seemed. I didn't get excited, just went about doing my job. I guess it will all end up as part of my PTSD later.
我们把它们都炸掉了，然后继续忙我们的事。奇怪的是，这一切显得多么正常。我没有激动，只是继续做我的工作。我想以后这一切都会成为我创伤后应激障碍的一部分。
I was talking to one of the villagers today, as I was watched by her seven kids. As I looked at the youngest of them, a little girl about my daughter's age, I saw a dirty face and a big toothy grin. She hid by Grandma Sabiya and just kept staring and smiling.
我今天和一个村民谈话，有七个孩子在盯着我看。当我看向他们最小的那个孩子，一个跟我女儿差不多大的小女孩时，我看到了她脏兮兮的脸和一口大大的牙齿笑容。她躲在Sabiya奶奶身后，只是盯着我看，笑着。
She was wearing sandals and a t-shirt and a seventh generation hand-me-down pair of pants. Here I was standing around wearing my desert uniform, wool socks, coat, body armor, and all my gear, and I was a little chilly. But these kids are dressed like we dress in the summer. It's not a matter of acclimation. They simply have no other choice.
她穿着凉鞋、T恤和第七代相传的一条裤子。而我站在这里，穿着沙漠迷彩、羊毛袜、大衣、防弹衣和所有的装备，还觉得有点冷。但这些孩子穿得就像我们夏天穿的那样。这不是适应的问题。他们根本别无选择。
I just wanted to give that little girl a pair of shoes and a warm smile, and tell her that people in America that have never met her care about her. I came over here thinking we should just bomb this place into a parking lot. I now think that as alien as this culture is, it may actually be worth saving. I figure that if I'm going to have to find mines, get shot at, and get blown up by IEDs, I might try to do some good here, too. God knows I'm way low on karma points.
我只是想给那个小女孩一双鞋和一个温暖的笑容，告诉她，在远方从未见过她的美国人关心她。我来这里时曾认为我们应该直接把这个地方炸成停车场。我现在认为，尽管这种文化很陌生，但它或许真的值得拯救。我想，如果我必须去排雷、被射击、被简易爆炸装置炸，我也许也能在这里做点好事。天知道我离好报差得远呢。
An hour later, a little kid throws a rock at my truck. It bounces off the gunner's turret, hits him in his sunglasses, shatters the lens, and gives the gunner one helluva shiner. So much for the shoes.
一小时后，一个小鬼朝我的卡车扔了一块石头。它从炮手的炮塔弹开，击中了他的太阳镜，镜片碎了，给炮手留下了一个倒霉的黑眼圈。鞋子的事就算了吧。
I showed him something else. Love, parental American style. I chased him on foot through the town, pulled his pants down in front of all of his little buddies, and spanked his bare ass right there on the street. If it's good enough for my kids, it's good enough for him.
我给了他点别的东西。爱，父母式的美国风格。我徒步在镇上追他，当着他所有小伙伴的面扒下他的裤子，就在街上给了他屁股一顿痛打。如果这对我自己的孩子管用，对他也就管用。
Pretty dull day today. I had a meeting with the sheik's council in al Hillah, which is like a county, with a local mayor and about 20 sheiks, and maybe three of them I trust. The head sheik, Sheik Adnan, looks like a very tan Lee Marvin. There's another one, Sheik Amir, who looks like Father Guido Sarducci from old SNL reruns. The Iraqi army major I work with, Major Karim looks, I swear, just like Eugene Levy from SCTV.
今天挺沉闷的。我和希拉的酋长委员会开了个会，那相当于一个县，当地市长和大约20个酋长在场，其中我信任的只有三个。酋长首领Adnan酋长看起来像个很黑的Lee Marvin。还有另一个，Amir酋长，看起来像老《周六夜现场》重播里的Guido Sarducci神父。和我一起工作的伊拉克陆军少校Karim，我发誓，长得就像SCTV里的Eugene Levy。
The sheiks all bitch about the same things. They want public works projects in their towns, and we want them to guarantee security and turn over terrorists to us. They balk and say that they can control their people, but people come from other areas to plant IEDs and attack Americans. We say, bull [BLEEP] and tell them that we can't pay for the public works until the area is secure. Lather, rinse and repeat. Third verse same as the first. I imagine this will go on for a year or so.
酋长们抱怨的都是同样的事情。他们想要公共工程项目，而我们要他们保证安全并把恐怖分子移交给我们。他们推诿说他们能控制住自己的人，但这些人是从其他地区过来埋设简易爆炸装置并攻击美国人的。我们说，放屁，并告诉他们，在地区安全之前我们不能支付公共工程费用。循环往复。第三句跟第一句一样。我想这种情况会持续一年左右。
Sheik Adnan is pretty likable and seems to be a pretty honest broker. He told me yesterday that sometimes he will have to say things to me in front of the other sheiks that he does not necessarily back. I understand that he has to do it to save face.
Adnan酋长相当讨人喜欢，看起来是个相当诚实的中间人。他昨天告诉我，有时他不得不在其他酋长面前对我说一些他未必支持的话。我理解他为了保全颜面必须这么做。
I also told him, in no uncertain terms, that I didn't really care what he said to me in front of the other sheiks as long as we remain respectful to each other. I told him that if he disrespects me, I will drag him through the streets in cuffs and put him in a very dark place. It seemed weird to say that to a 50-year-old man, but he smiled and told me that he was glad to see that I had backbone, and that there are very few people who would ever say that to his face and he respects me for it.
我也明确告诉他，只要我们保持彼此尊重，我根本不在乎他在其他酋长面前对我说什么。我告诉他，如果他不尊重我，我会拖着他走过街道，给他戴上手铐，然后把他关进一个很黑的地方。对一个50岁的人说这种话感觉很奇怪，但他笑了，并告诉我他很高兴看到我有骨气，很少有人会当面这么对他，他因此尊重我。
He asked me if I was a prince or a sheik in America, because I had so many tanks and soldiers. I didn't want to tell him the truth, because it would actually hurt my position with him. So I told him that America does not have princes or sheiks, but I was personally commissioned by the President of the United States and placed in command of the company under his authority. This, of course, is true, but not exactly forthcoming. He was very impressed by that.
他问我，在美国我是王子还是酋长，因为我有这么多坦克和士兵。我不想告诉他真相，因为那会损害我和他的关系。所以我告诉他，美国没有王子或酋长，但我是由美国总统亲自委派的，并在他的授权下指挥这个连队。这当然是真的，但不完全坦诚。他对此印象非常深刻。
Did you know that in America they have machines that make clouds come? I didn't either until we found out from an Iraqi man at the gas station. And thank God our body armor has those internal cooling units. If I didn't have that micro air conditioner inside, then I'd just be walking around with a 30-pound vest in 110 degree heat.
你知道美国有制造云彩的机器吗？我也不知道，直到我们在加油站从一个伊拉克人那里得知。感谢上帝，我们的防弹衣有那种内置冷却装置。如果我里面没有那个微型空调，我就得穿着30磅重的背心在110度的高温下走来走去。
Oh, and I don't know where I'd be without my sunglasses. Unfortunately, many Iraqis have figured out that they allow me to see weapons through people's clothing. I don't know where they get this stuff from, but if myths about American technology make someone think twice about attacking us, then I guess I can't complain.
哦，如果没我的太阳镜我不知道该怎么办。不幸的是，许多伊拉克人已经发现它能让我透过衣服看到武器。我不知道他们从哪弄来的这些说法，但如果关于美国技术的传说能让某人在攻击我们前三思，那我想我就没什么好抱怨的了。
This is Trueman Muhrer-Irwin. He blogs at livejournal. com under the name rebelcoyote. He's originally from Chicago. He joined the Army National Guard, served as a Private First Class in Alpha Company Third Battalion 124th Infantry.
这是Trueman Muhrer-Irwin。他在livejournal.com以rebelcoyote的名字写博客。他来自芝加哥。他加入了陆军国民警卫队，在Alpha连第3营124步兵团担任一等兵。
We had just finished the DVD of Friends , season three, and me, Micah, and Jared had all sat down to watch season four. We were all having a good time. Ross and Rachel were getting back together after a weekend retreat to the beach. Phoebe discovered who  her real mother was. Joey dug a hole. Chandler made snide remarks. And in Baghdad, a suicide bomber drove a vehicle packed with explosives up to the Turkish Embassy and detonated it, killing himself and injuring at least two embassy workers.
我们刚看完DVD《老友记》第三季，我和Micah还有Jared都坐下来准备看第四季。我们玩得很开心。罗斯和瑞秋在去海滩度假后又走到了一起。菲比发现了自己的亲生母亲。乔伊挖了个洞。钱德勒冷嘲热讽。而在巴格达，一名自杀式炸弹袭击者驾驶着装满炸药的车辆冲向土耳其大使馆并引爆了它，炸死了他自己，至少炸伤了两名大使馆工作人员。
The blast, no more than a mile away from our compound, shook the walls. The doors rattled. The windows of our supply room cracked. The explosion was louder than the RPG that struck our compound two months earlier.
爆炸距离我们的营地不到一英里，震动了墙壁。门嘎嘎作响。我们供应室的窗户裂了。爆炸声比两个月前击中我们营地的火箭推进榴弹声还要大。
It still doesn't seem real, none of this. Even the biggest explosions seem like special effects in a long, drawn out training exercise. It was still hard to believe that this is real, that people are dying. And  that the events that make CNN headlines, the kind of stuff that's passed in my peripheral awareness my entire life is happening a mile away from where I sleep.
这似乎还是不真实，这一切都不是真的。即使最大的爆炸也像一场漫长、拖沓的训练演习中的特效。仍然很难相信这是真的，人们正在死去。而且那些登上CNN头条的事件，那些我一生都在边缘意识中经过的东西，竟然就在我睡觉的地方一英里外发生。
After this entry on Trueman's blog, there are a couple more entries, and then on November 9, 2003, the entries stop. Five days later, this message appears on the blog from his friend, Emily. "Hi, all. This is Emy, updating on behalf of rebelcoyote. To start with, Trueman is going to be OK, however, he won't be updating for a while." She goes on to say that Trueman's been injured. He's in hospital in Germany. He'll write again when he can.
在Trueman博客的这篇日志之后，还有几篇，然后2003年11月9日，日志停止了。五天后，博客上出现了他朋友Emily的这条信息。“大家好，我是Emy，代rebelcoyote更新。首先，Trueman会没事的，但他暂时不会更新了。”她接着说Trueman受了伤。他在德国的医院。他能写的时候会再写的。
Then, just over a week later at midnight, November 17, Trueman comes back to tell what happened.
然后，一周多一点后的11月17日午夜，Trueman回来讲述发生了什么。
We were on our way to pick up a few things from our compound. If we were going to spend the rest of the week at First AD Brigade headquarters, we were sure as hell going to have all our stuff. We were just going to make a quick stop at the barracks, then head over to gunner main.
我们在去营地取几样东西的路上。如果我们要在那里的总部过完剩下的一周，我们一定要拿回所有的东西。我们打算在军营做个快速停留，然后前往枪手驻地。
As we were coming up towards River Road, I stared out at the street, pulling security from behind the 50 cal. Then all of a sudden something hit me. It felt like we'd driven under a low bridge or maybe someone had hit me with a brick. It took almost a full second to realize what had happened.
当我们驶向河路时，我盯着街道，从50口径机枪后方执行警戒。然后突然有什么东西击中了我不。感觉就像我们开进了一座低矮的桥下，或者有人用砖头砸了我。过了整整一秒钟，我才意识到发生了什么。
The smoke and the dust were all around us. There was no sound but the dull ringing in my head, and all I could smell was blood. I began to feel frantically around my throat for wounds as the voice of platoon medic Matt Moss pierced the silence. Get away from the vehicle, he screamed. He was right. The gas tanks could go or someone could be waiting with an RPG for the dust to clear.
烟尘在我们周围。除了头部的嗡嗡声，没有其他声音，我只能闻到血腥味。我开始疯狂地摸索喉咙查看伤口，这时排里的医护兵Matt Moss的声音穿透了沉默。“离开车辆！”他尖叫道。他是对的。油箱可能会爆炸，或者有人可能在等灰尘散去，准备用火箭推进榴弹攻击。
When I lowered myself to the ground, I looked through the missing windshield and saw Wise, still motionless in the passenger seat. His head was tilted back and his face was covered in blood.
当我落到地面时，我透过缺失的挡风玻璃看到Wise，他依然一动不动地坐在副驾驶座。他的头向后仰，脸上满是鲜血。
Help me move him, Matt shouted. I can't, I yelled. I think my foot's broken. As I hopped off to the side of the road and sat down, I realized that my foot was not only broken, but pouring a steady stream of blood from the left side.
“帮我把他移走！”Matt大喊。“我不能，”我吼道。“我想我的脚断了。”当我跳到路边坐下时，我意识到我的脚不仅断了，左侧还在持续不断地流血。
Through gritted teeth and intense pain, I unlaced my boot and pulled it off. The left side of my sock was entirely soaked and dripping with blood, but the right side was a large charred patch of indistinguishable skin, sock, and shrapnel.
伴随着咬牙切齿和剧烈的疼痛，我解开了靴子脱掉。袜子左侧完全被浸透，滴着血，而右侧是一大块分辨不出是皮肤、袜子还是弹片的焦块。
I'm going to lose my foot, I thought. Then Matt's voice broke through my self-absorbed agony. Come on, Wise, breathe, he shouted. God damn it, breathe. You're not going to die here.
“我要失去我的脚了，”我想。然后Matt的声音穿透了我自我沉浸的痛苦。“得了吧，Wise，呼吸！”他吼道。“该死的，呼吸。你不会死在这里的。”
I shouldn't be worried about my foot while one of my best friends is dying 10 feet away, but it hurt so bad. Wise and I were loaded onto a Blackhawk and evaced to the hospital at the palace. They'd gotten him breathing again. They said he'd be OK.
我不该在我最好的朋友之一在10英尺外濒死时担心自己的脚，但它痛得太厉害了。Wise和我都上了黑鹰直升机，被送往宫殿的医院。他们让他重新开始呼吸。他们说他会没事的。
At the hospital, they gave me morphine. It didn't do much for the pain, but Wise was going to be OK, and once the doctor pulled the shrapnel out, he said I wasn't going to lose my foot. All in all, I was in a good mood. Maybe it was just the drugs, but I knew everything was going to be fine.
在医院，他们给了我吗啡。它对疼痛没起到太大作用，但Wise会没事的，一旦医生取出弹片，他们说我不会失去我的脚。总而言之，我的心情还不错。也许只是药物的作用，但我知道一切都会好起来的。
The doctors put me under for surgery. They cleaned out my wound and cut away the dead burned tissue. When I woke up, I didn't feel any pain. I still had my foot. I was going to be back in the States in a week.
医生给我做了全身麻醉手术。他们清理了伤口，切除了坏死的烧伤组织。当我醒来时，我没有任何疼痛。我的脚还在。我一周后就能回到国内了。
Then I found out that Wise, the guy I had spent the last nine months getting to know better than any one else, died of massive head trauma while I was in surgery. He'll be buried at Arlington National Cemetery next week.
然后我发现Wise，那个我过去九个月里了解得比任何人都深的朋友，在我手术时死于严重的头部创伤。他下周将被安葬在阿灵顿国家公墓。
This is all a dream. Any second now, [UNINTELLIGIBLE] going to wake me up for a guard shift. Any second now, I'm going to climb grudgingly out of my bed and look across through the dim light and see Wise. He'll be making that face again, the one that's questioning how many people he'd have to kill to go back to sleep.
这一切都是一场梦。再过一秒，[乱码]就会叫醒我换岗。再过一秒，我会不情愿地爬出床，透过昏暗的光线望向对面，看到Wise。他会再次露出那个表情，那个质问他还要杀多少人才能回去睡觉的表情。
We'll get dressed, drag our feet up to the roof, and spend a miserable three hours in the freezing wind staring down at the road. Maybe he'll tell me about his job at Greybar or an anecdote from his days as JROTC Corps Commander. I might tell him about Chicago and why things didn't work out with my last girlfriend.
我们会穿好衣服，拖着脚走到屋顶，在冷风中盯着马路度过悲惨的三个小时。也许他会告诉我他在Greybar的工作，或者他担任初级预备役军官团指挥官时期的轶事。我可能会告诉他芝加哥，以及我上一个女朋友为什么没成。
We'll nod and pretend we haven't heard the stories before. We'll bitch about our leaders and talk about our plans when we get home. Maybe Wise will even pull out a three-by-five card and draw up the floor plan for his house again.
我们会点点头，假装没听过这些故事。我们会抱怨我们的领导，谈论我们回家后的计划。也许Wise还会拿出那张3x5的卡片，再次画出他房子的平面图。
Any second now we'll wake up, and Wise won't be dead. Because he can't be dead. People only die in the newspapers. But the seconds pass, and I don't wake up to anything but sterile sheets and pain.
再过一秒我们就会醒来，而Wise不会死。因为他不可能死。人们只死在报纸上。但时间一秒秒过去，我醒来看到的只有消毒过的床单和疼痛。
I never thought I'd join the army. I've had a fairly liberal pacifist upbringing and couldn't imagine myself as a soldier. I feel funny admitting it now, but ultimately, it was the college money that got me. It seemed like a good deal. I knew that even if I got sent overseas, the worst case scenario was a rotation in Bosnia. I wouldn't be gone more than six months.
我从没想过我会参军。我受的是相当自由主义、和平主义的教育，无法想象自己会成为一名士兵。我现在承认这一点感觉很奇怪，但最终，是大学学费诱惑了我。这看起来是个不错的交易。我知道即使我被派往海外，最坏的情况也就是在波斯尼亚轮换。我离开的时间不会超过六个月。
I hated the way this war started. It took me a long time to come to terms with my role as a soldier in Iraq. Eventually, I came to realize that, although the method was flawed, the result was freedom for the people for the first time in 30 years.
我讨厌这场战争开始的方式。我花了好长时间才接受我在伊拉克作为一名士兵的角色。最终，我意识到，虽然方法是有缺陷的，但结果是让那里的民众在30年来第一次获得了自由。
People don't hear the good things from the news, and I'll admit that even I have trouble taking the things that come from the White House Press Room seriously. But no one hears about the people who bring us food in the streets and take their children out to shake our hands.
人们在新闻里听不到好的事情，我也承认即使是我也很难认真对待白宫新闻发布室传来的东西。但没人听说过那些在街上给我们送食物，带孩子出来和我们握手的人。
We established the first garbage collection system in Baghdad's history. We've arrested dozens of corrupt gas station managers to keep gas prices stable. And I can't think of the last time I heard someone mention the sanctions, which killed hundreds of thousands of Iraqis and are now over.
我们建立了巴格达历史上第一个垃圾收集系统。我们逮捕了数十名腐败的加油站经理以保持油价稳定。而且我记不起上次听到有人提到制裁是什么时候了，那些制裁害死了数十万伊拉克人，现在已经结束了。
We have no choice but to finish the job we started. Anything less would be disastrous for the Iraqi people. Anything less would mean that every person who died here did it for nothing. And Wise didn't die for nothing.
我们别无选择，只能完成我们开始的工作。任何其他的结局对伊拉克人民来说都是灾难性的。任何其他的结局都意味着每一个死在这里的人都是徒劳的。而Wise没有白白牺牲。
I'm back in the US now. I have a long and difficult road ahead of me. Even once my foot is healed, it will take months of physical therapy before I can walk again. But the important thing is I will walk again.
我现在回到了美国。我的前路漫长而艰难。即使我的脚愈合了，在能再次行走前也需要几个月的物理治疗。但重要的是，我还会再次行走。
I get asked about my foot a lot. People ask me what happened or how I hurt it, in elevators, in the airport, asking about an apparently simple injury. A foot in a thick ace bandage wrap seems to be acceptable small talk, like, nice weather today, huh?
我经常被问到关于我的脚的问题。人们问我发生了什么或我怎么弄伤的，在电梯里，在机场，询问着一个看似简单的伤。一只缠着厚弹性绷带的脚似乎是一个可以接受的小谈资，就像“今天天气不错，对吧？”
It's not that I mind, it's just that it's awkward, because when I tell them what happened, they never know what to say. It sounds so weird. It was a roadside bomb in Baghdad. Sometimes I say it and it doesn't even sound true. I feel like I'm making it up.
我并不是介意，只是这很尴尬，因为当我告诉他们发生了什么时，他们永远不知道该说什么。听起来太奇怪了。那是巴格达的路边炸弹。有时我说出来，甚至听起来都不真实。我觉得自己在编造它。
Then there's the people who ask things like, how did you break it, or did you fall down the stairs, or the lady who said, oh, I had arch problems once. Not like this, lady. I guarantee you.
还有那些问类似“你怎么弄断的，你是从楼梯上摔下来的吗？”的人，或者那个说“哦，我以前脚弓也有问题”的女士。不是这样的，女士。我保证。
When I tell people what happened, some people are really nice. They shake my hand and thank me. Others just say things like, wow, that sucks, or, oh, I'm sorry, and look slightly embarrassed. I feel weird saying it, and they feel weird hearing it. I've honestly considered telling people I sprained my ankle. I think it may only be a matter of time before I do.
当我告诉人们发生了什么，有些人真的很友善。他们和我握手，感谢我。其他人只是说些类似“哇，真糟糕”或者“哦，我很遗憾”，看起来有点尴尬。我说出来感到奇怪，他们听的时候也感到奇怪。我真的考虑过告诉人们我扭伤了脚踝。我想可能迟早我会这么做的。
The third blogger is Colby Buzzell, who had a really popular blog, thousands of readers, called My War: Killing Time in Iraq. Since he got back to the States, he's taken lots of these entries, added some new stuff, and published it as a book under the same name. He was a machine gunner in the Third Arrowhead Brigade Second Infantry Division out of Fort Lewis, serving in Mosul.
第三位博主是Colby Buzzell，他有一个非常受欢迎的博客，成千上万的读者，叫做《我的战争：在伊拉克消磨时间》。自从他回到国内，他收集了许多这些条目，增加了一些新内容，并以同样的名字出版了一本书。他是来自刘易斯堡第2步兵师第3箭头旅的机枪手，在摩苏尔服役。
20 October, '03. Another brief at Carey Theater. The second half was about rules of engagement. A female captain came out and asked us a hypothetical, what-if question. If your convoy was going under an overpass and there was women and children on the overpass throwing rocks down at us, what should you do? Do you shoot or not shoot?
03年10月20日。在凯里剧院又做了一次简报。后半部分是关于交战规则。一位女上尉出来问我们一个假设性的、如果的问题。如果你们的车队穿过一座立交桥，上面有妇女和儿童往下扔石头，你们该怎么做？开火还是不开火？
The first answer that came to my head was, no. You don't engage. You don't fire unless you see  a weapon, so, no, I would not fire. I wonder why she said, women and children, like why not say, people, instead, or was women and children for effect?
我脑子里蹦出的第一个答案是，不。你们不交战。除非你看到武器，否则你不开火，所以，不，我不会开火。我想知道她为什么说“妇女和儿童”，比如为什么不说“人”呢，还是说“妇女和儿童”是为了效果？
One soldier in the auditorium instantly yelled out, light 'em up, which was followed by some laughter. But there was also people in the auditorium that disagreed with the light 'em up answer. As soldiers were debating with each other on what should be done in a situation like that, the battalion commander stepped up, and I could tell that he wasn't really digging on what this captain was trying to do here.
礼堂里的一名士兵立刻大喊，“干掉他们”，这引来了一些笑声。但也有些人不同意“干掉他们”的回答。当士兵们在争论在这种情况下该怎么做时，营长走了上来，我看得出他并不喜欢这位上尉在这里试图做的事情。
And he asked us all a non-hypothetical question. How many of you been in combat? Several people raised their hands. The captain, I noticed, did not.
他问了我们大家一个非假设性的问题。有多少人经历过战斗？几个人举起了手。我注意到，那位上尉没举手。
How many of you have been shot at? Almost all the raised hands stayed raised. Then you understand that it doesn't matter if it's a woman or a child. If they have a weapon, they have a weapon. If you feel threatened, you feel threatened.
有多少人被射击过？几乎所有举起的手都保持着。那么你们就应该明白，是妇女还是儿童并不重要。如果他们有武器，他们就有武器。如果你感到被威胁，你就被威胁了。
He then told us all not to worry about doing the right thing, that if we wanted to do the right thing to go out and rent a Spike Lee movie. He then stressed to us that if we felt threatened, pull the trigger. It's better to be safe than sorry. Better him dead than  you.
然后他告诉大家不要担心做正确的事，如果想做正确的事就去租一部斯派克·李的电影。他接着强调，如果我们感到被威胁，就扣动扳机。安全总比后悔好。死他总比死你好。
We were engaged in a huge fire fight at the [UNINTELLIGIBLE] police station and the mosque next door to it. It took hours. Then at the end, the ING, Iraqi National Guard, showed up.
我们当时正卷入[乱码]警察局和隔壁清真寺的一场大型交火中。持续了好几个小时。最后，ING，也就是伊拉克国民警卫队赶到了。
Our platoon leader chose a couple soldiers from our platoon to talk to the media, who wanted to find out what went down today in Mosul. A high ranking army public affairs officer, a lieutenant colonel, briefed them on what they could and could not say.
我们的排长选了几个士兵去和媒体谈话，媒体想了解今天摩苏尔发生了什么。一位陆军公共事务高级官员，一名中校，简要告知了他们什么能说，什么不能说。
All three told me that he stressed to them to tell the media that the insurgents fired first, and we were there just to return fire, which is true. But he also told them, do not say that TOW missiles were used in the attack, but to instead say, internal weapon systems were used.
三个人都告诉我，他强调要告诉媒体是叛军先开的火，我们只是在那还击，这是事实。但他还告诉他们，不要说攻击中使用了陶式导弹，而是要说“使用了内部武器系统”。
Whatever. That's no big deal. That's like saying instead of telling the media that you returned fire with your M-4, tell them that you returned fire with your self defense mechanism.
随便吧。那没什么大不了的。那就像是不告诉媒体你用M-4还击，而是告诉他们你用“自我防御机制”还击一样。
But then he told them to flat out lie when he said, do not mention the fact that the Iraqi police fled from the mosque and the police station, how they didn't even put up a fight, but instead, tell the media that they fought well and did an excellent job.
但随后他竟然叫他们撒谎，说不要提及伊拉克警察从清真寺和警察局逃跑的事实，也不要说他们甚至没进行反抗，而是告诉媒体他们打得很好，做了出色的工作。
To make sure I'd never run out of reading material, I subscribed to as many magazines as possible before I left the States. I went to the mag rack at the PX and grabbed as many of those annoying subscription slips as I could.
为了确保我永远不会没东西看，我离开国内前订阅了尽可能多的杂志。我走到PX的杂志架前，尽可能多地抓了那些烦人的订阅单。
I find that infantry men are into macho testosterone literature when it comes to monthly periodicals, mags like 4X4 Monthly, Guns & Ammo, Outdoor World, Soldier of Fortune, which I subscribe to just for the articles, and, of course, the soft core bubble gum skin mags, like Maxim, FHM, and Stuff.
我发现步兵对于月刊杂志更倾向于那种充满大男子主义睾酮的读物，比如《4X4月刊》、《枪支与弹药》、《户外世界》、《雇佣兵》（我订阅这个纯粹为了文章），当然还有那些软色情的口香糖皮肤杂志，比如《Maxim》、《FHM》和《Stuff》。
Pornography in magazines, like Playboy and Penthouse, are, of course, not allowed in Iraq for reasons that have to do with not offending anyone and being sensitive to the Islamic culture or some [BLEEP] like that. So I subscribed to magazines that I liked, but knew not a lot of other soldiers read, like Thrasher, MAD, National Geographic, TIME, and Details. To this day, I seriously have no idea why the [BLEEP] I subscribed to Details, which I caught a lot of hell for and brought up a bunch of questions about my sexuality among fellow squad members.
像《花花公子》和《阁楼》这种杂志上的色情内容，当然在伊拉克是不允许的，理由是不能冒犯任何人，以及要对伊斯兰文化保持敏感，诸如此类的[屏蔽词]。所以我订阅了那些我喜欢但知道没多少其他士兵会读的杂志，比如《Thrasher》、《MAD》、《国家地理》、《时代》和《Details》。直到今天，我都不知道我为什么要订阅那个[屏蔽词]的《Details》，为此我倒了大霉，还引来了同排成员对我性取向的怀疑。
Every mail call, I would dread whenever the new issue would arrive, because my squad leader would read off the name of whoever the letter or package was addressed to. Then he'd flip it over and show the rest of the squad the cover, which would always be some sexy cover shot of like Vin Diesel or Justin Timberlake. Then he'd throw the mag at me and say something like, don't ask, don't tell.
每次信件送达时，只要有新一期杂志到，我就会感到恐惧，因为我的排长会读出信件或包裹上的名字。然后他会把它翻过来，把封面展示给其余的小队看，封面通常是一些像范·迪塞尔或贾斯汀·汀布莱克之类的性感封面照。然后他会把杂志扔给我，说些类似“不说不问”的话。
Of course, every one in my squad would get a laugh out of this and say things like, dude, you're a homo. And I, of course, would feel the need to explain myself. Look, dude, Details is not a mag for gay people. Check it out. There's tons of hot chicks in it.
当然，小队里的每个人都会以此为乐，说些类似“伙计，你是个同性恋”的话。我当然觉得需要解释自己。“看，伙计，《Details》不是一本给同性恋看的杂志。自己看看。里面有成堆的热辣美女。”
And I would open it up and flip through the pages and try to prove to the guys in my squad that Details was a totally hetero mag, which kind of backfired on me, because when I did this, every single page that I opened to was a full page photo of some girly man doing his best Zoolander.
于是我把它翻开，尝试证明给小队的伙计们看《Details》是一本完全异性恋的杂志，这结果适得其反，因为当我这样做时，我翻到的每一页都是那种极力模仿《超级名模》里的“娘娘腔”的全页照片。
Thursday, August 4, 2004. Men in black. I was in my room reading a book, Thin Red Line, when the mortar started coming down. Usually when we get mortared, it's usually one or maybe two mortars. But this mortar attack went on for like 20 minutes. Sergeant Horrach ripped open the door and yelled, grab your guys and go down to the motor pool. The whole battalion is rolling out. Holy [BLEEP]. The whole battalion? This must be big.
2004年8月4日星期四。黑衣人。我当时在房间里看一本书，叫《细细的红线》，这时迫击炮开始落下。通常当我们遭到炮击时，也就是一两枚迫击炮。但这次炮击持续了大约20分钟。Horrach中士猛地推开门吼道，“带上你们的人去车辆修理区。整个营都要出动了。”天哪。整个营？这肯定是大动作。
One by one, the strikers were rolling out of the motor pool ready to hunt down whoever was [BLEEP] with us. Soldiers in the hatches of the vehicles were hooting and hollering and doing the Indian yell thing as they drove off and locked and loaded their weapons.
斯特瑞克装甲车一辆接一辆从修理区驶出，准备去追捕那些[屏蔽词]我们的人。车辆舱盖里的士兵在驱车离开时一边发出印第安式的呐喊，一边锁定武器，准备战斗。
As I turned on all our computers and radios inside our vehicle to get ready to roll out, I heard on the radio that the [BLEEP] was hitting the fan all over Mosul. Large amounts of AIF, anti-Iraqi forces, were attacking us with small arms, IEDs, and RPG fire. And there was a bunch of people wearing all black armed with AK-47s all over Mosul.
当我打开车内所有的电脑和收音机准备出发时，我从收音机里听到到处都乱成了一锅粥。大量AIF，也就是反伊拉克武装部队，正用轻武器、简易爆炸装置和火箭推进榴弹袭击我们。摩苏尔到处都是身穿全黑衣服、手持AK-47的人。
I was sticking out of my hatch behind the 50 cal. I glanced over to the left side of the vehicle at which time I observed a man, dressed in all black with a terrorist beard, jump out all of a sudden from the side of a building. He pointed his AK barrel right at my [BLEEP] pupils.
我探身在舱盖外，站在50口径机枪后面。我瞥向车辆左侧，这时观察到一个穿着全黑衣服、留着恐怖分子胡须的男人突然从建筑物侧面跳出来。他直接把AK枪管对着我的[屏蔽词]瞳孔。
I saw the fire from his muzzle flash leaving the end of his AK as he was shooting directly at me. I heard and felt the bullets whiz literally inches from my head, hitting all around my hatch and 50 cal mount, making a ping, ping, ping sound.
我看到了他扣动扳机时枪口的火焰，感觉到子弹离我的头仅有几英寸，击中了我舱盖和机枪底座周围，发出叮、叮、叮的声音。
We were driving down route Tampa. All hell suddenly came down around us. Out of nowhere, all these guys wearing all black, a couple dozen on each side of the street and rooftops, alleys, edge of buildings, out of windows, everywhere, just came out out of nowhere and started unloading on us. IEDs were being ignited on both sides of the street. I freaked the [BLEEP] and ducked down in the hatch, and I yelled over the radio, holy [BLEEP]. We got [BLEEP] Hajis all over the [BLEEP] place. They're all over, god damn it.
我们开在坦帕公路上。一切突然间变得地狱般混乱。不知从哪冒出来，这些穿着黑衣服的家伙，街道两边和屋顶、巷子里、建筑物边缘、窗户外，到处都是，突然出现，向我们倾泻火力。简易爆炸装置在街道两边引爆。我惊恐万分，躲进舱盖，对着收音机吼道，“该死的，到处都是[屏蔽词]哈吉人。他们到处都是，该死的。”
Bullets were pinging all over our armor, and you could hear multiple RPGs being fired and soaring through the air in every which way, and impacting all around us. All sorts of crazy, insane Hollywood explosions were going off. I was like, this is it. I'm going to die. I cannot put into words how scared I was.
子弹叮叮当当地击中我们的装甲，你可以听到无数的火箭推进榴弹被发射，在空中四处乱飞，在我们周围爆炸。各种疯狂的、好莱坞式的爆炸声此起彼伏。我心想，就是现在。我要死了。我无法用言语形容我当时有多害怕。
The vehicle in front of us, Bravo Victor 2 1 was getting hit by multiple RPGs. I kind of lost it and was yelling and screaming all sorts of things, mostly cuss words. With RPGs still flying, our driver floored it, pedal to the metal, and red lined the vehicle right through the ambush as fast as he could.
我们前面的那辆车，“Bravo Victor 2 1”，遭到了多枚火箭推进榴弹的攻击。我有点崩溃了，尖叫着喊着各种话，主要是脏话。火箭推进榴弹还在飞，我们的司机猛踩油门，加足马力，把车开到了极限速度，飞快地冲过了伏击圈。
Finally, we fired our way out of the kill zone and made our way over to bridge five. We parked the vehicle and dismounted. I lit up a smoke and started to scan my sector. The Pepsi bottling plant across the street was all up in flames. Then after a couple minutes we were told to load back up and go back to where we got ambushed.
最后，我们从杀戮区域冲了出来，开到了五号桥。我们停车并下车。我点了一根烟，开始扫描我的区域。街对面的百事可乐装瓶厂陷入火海。几分钟后，我们被告知重新装车，回到我们遭到伏击的地方。
I'm not going to lie. I didn't want to go back. I didn't want to get killed. I was scared to death, but we had to go back, and we did.
我不会撒谎。我不想回去。我不想被杀。我怕得要死，但我们必须回去，我们确实回去了。
We drove back to the area where we had just dodged death and were taking fire from all over. I fired and fired and fired and fired at everything. We were running low on 50 cal ammunition at this point, and my platoon sergeant, Sergeant Horner, told me to reload. He told me that the ammo was dropped down on the outside of the vehicle over on the right side. Why the [BLEEP] would the ammo for the 50 cal be on the outside of the vehicle?
我们开回了那个我们刚逃过一劫的区域，再次遭到四面八方的射击。我开火、开火、开火、再开火，射向一切。这时我们的50口径机枪弹药不多了，排军士Horner中士让我重新装填。他告诉我在车辆外侧右下方掉落了弹药。为什么[屏蔽词]50口径的弹药会在车辆外面？
With my hands I did the sign of the cross on my chest, said a prayer, please, God, I don't want to [BLEEP] die. And as my platoon sergeant laid down some suppressive fire with his M-4, I got up out of the hatch, got my whole body completely out of the vehicle, and walked on the top of our vehicle to find the box of 50 cal ammunition.
我用手在胸前画了个十字，祈祷，请，上帝，我不想[屏蔽词]死。就在我排长用M-4进行压制射击时，我从舱盖里爬出来，把全身完全探出车辆，走在车顶寻找50口径弹药箱。
I was shaking and scared out of my [BLEEP] mind as I did this, and thinking to myself that having ammo located on the outside of the vehicle has got to be the dumbest, [BLEEP] idea in the world, and whoever thought of that idea should be [BLEEP] shot.
我浑身发抖，被吓得[屏蔽词]丢了魂，心里想着，把弹药放在车辆外面绝对是世界上最愚蠢的[屏蔽词]主意，想出这个主意的人应该被[屏蔽词]枪毙。
I saw a crowd of people suspiciously peeking around a corner at us. I pointed this out to Sergeant Horner and asked him what I should do. As he was shooting nonstop from his hatch in the heat of the moment, he told me to just [BLEEP] shoot them, and he explained to me that these people have no [BLEEP] business out on the street whatsoever right now.
我看到一伙人可疑地从拐角向我们探头探脑。我指给Horner中士看，问他我该怎么办。他正忙着在舱盖里不停地射击，他让我就直接[屏蔽词]射击他们，并向我解释说这些人现在根本就不应该出现在街上。
So I pointed the crosshairs at them, but then I moved it right above their heads and fired a burst, which got them to disperse in a hurry. I could tell that they were just spectators.
于是我瞄准他们，但把准星移到了他们头上方开了一枪，这让他们迅速散开。我看得出他们只是看热闹的。
Suddenly, about 300 meters away from us, over by the traffic circle, I saw two guys with those red and white jihad towels wrapped around their heads creeping around a corner. They were hunched down hiding behind a stack of tires. I could tell by their body language something was up.
突然，离我们大约300米远的地方，在交通环岛附近，我看到两个头上裹着那种红白圣战头巾的家伙正绕过拐角。他们弓着身子躲在一堆轮胎后面。从他们的肢体语言我能看出不对劲。
I placed the crosshairs on them and was about to [BLEEP] waste them, but for some reason I didn't pull the trigger. These guys were not dressed in black like the guys earlier, and from what I could see, they didn't have any weapons on them. Something told me that I should just wait one, maybe two, more seconds.
我把准星对准他们，正要[屏蔽词]干掉他们，但由于某种原因我没扣动扳机。这些家伙不像之前那群人穿黑衣服，而且我看得出他们身上没武器。某种直觉告诉我应该再等一秒，也许两秒。
Then I saw another guy creeping around that corner with an RPG in his hand. As soon as I saw that, I yelled, RPG, as loud as I could into the CVC. My crosshairs were bouncing all over, so I gather my composure as fast as I could, put the crosshairs on them, and engaged them with a good 10 round bursts of some 50 cal right at them. Nobody moved from behind those tires after that.
然后我看到另一个人手里拿着火箭推进榴弹从那个拐角绕过来。我一看到那个，就对着通信系统尽可能大声地喊道，“RPG”。我的准星在到处乱跳，所以我尽可能快地定下神，把准星对准他们，用大约10发的50口径机枪点射向他们开火。在那之后，轮胎后面没人动弹了。
This gun fight has been going on for four and a half hours when the ING's, Iraqi National Guard, finally showed up to the party-- about [BLEEP] time-- in their ING pickup trucks all jam packed with ING soldiers in uniform armed with AK-47s. We had to return to FOB Marez as we were running extremely low on fuel, ammo, and water, so we all mounted up and drove back to the FOB.
这场枪战持续了四个半小时，当ING（伊拉克国民警卫队）终于赶到现场时——[屏蔽词]终于到了——开着他们的皮卡车，上面挤满了穿着制服、武装着AK-47的士兵。我们不得不返回马雷兹前进作战基地，因为我们的燃料、弹药和水都极度短缺，所以我们装车撤回了基地。
I was smoking like a chimney, one right after another. My nerves were completely shot, and I was emotionally drained, and I noticed that my hands were still kind of shaking. I was thinking how lucky I was to be alive.
我像个烟囱一样一根接一根地抽烟。我的神经完全崩溃了，情感上也彻底枯竭了，我注意到我的手还在发抖。我在想自己活着是多么幸运。
I've never experienced anything like the fear I felt today. A couple times today I thought about that guy who jumped out from the corner of that building with that angry look on his face when he pointed the AK at my head and pulled the trigger.
我从未经历过像今天这样的恐惧。今天有好几次，我想到那个从楼角跳出来、脸上一副愤怒表情、把AK枪管对着我的头并扣动扳机的那家伙。
The attacks on my platoon up to this point had been just chicken [BLEEP], hit and run bull [BLEEP]. Every time we'd get hit, they'd be nowhere in sight. These guys today were on the offensive. They held their ground and showed no fear of us whatsoever.
到目前为止，对我排的攻击都只是小儿科，打了就跑的[屏蔽词]。每次我们挨打时，他们都没影了。而今天这些人是主动出击。他们守住阵地，对我们毫无畏惧。
Before that ambush, I received a lot of emails from people and I'd just scan over them briefly, but then when I posted the men in black entry, my blog blew up like an IED on route Tampa. I was getting emails from people all over the United States, Europe, Canada, South America, as well as soldiers in Kuwait, Afghanistan, and Iraq.
在那次伏击之前，我收到了很多人的邮件，我也只是匆匆扫过，但当我发布了那篇关于黑衣人的条目后，我的博客就像坦帕公路上的简易爆炸装置一样爆了。我收到了来自美国各地、欧洲、加拿大、南美以及科威特、阿富汗和伊拉克士兵的邮件。
Soldiers I didn't even know at FOB Marez were emailing me. Even the helicopter pilots that flew above us on missions were emailing. That's when I knew my blog was huge, once I started getting emails from the helicopter pilots.
甚至基地里我不认识的士兵都在给我发邮件。连在我们执行任务时从空中飞过的直升机飞行员都在发。那时我就知道我的博客火了，因为开始收到飞行员的邮件。
Every now and then I'd get an email that said things like, thank you for serving. I enjoyed your articles until you took off with the bad words. I, for one, am sorry that I won't be able to read about your experiences anymore.
偶尔我会收到一些邮件说，“感谢你的服务。我很喜欢你的文章，直到你用了脏话。我个人很遗憾以后不能再读你的经历了。”
I always ignored and deleted those kinds of emails. [BLEEP] them. If they don't like the swear words, they can go read somebody else's [BLEEP] blog.
我总是忽略并删除那些邮件。[屏蔽词]他们。如果他们不喜欢脏话，就去读别人的[屏蔽词]博客。
About a week or so before this in the back of the Striker during a mounted patrol, Specialst Cummings asked me if I knew anything about a soldier in Mosul who did a blog. Habee and I just kind of looked at each other, and I asked Cummings why.
这事大概一周前，在斯特瑞克装甲车内的一次巡逻途中，Cummings中士问我是否知道摩苏尔有个写博客的士兵。Habee和我互相看了看，我问Cummings为什么。
He told me that his parents emailed him, asking him if he knew anything about it. Habee and I just laughed, so I told Cummings all about it. And he told me all about how his father saves all the entries that I write on a separate file and goes through it all and deletes all the cuss words and swear words out of it, so that way his mom could be able to read it.
他告诉我，他父母发邮件问他是否知道这事。Habee和我大笑起来，于是我把一切都告诉了Cummings。他跟我说了他父亲是如何把我写的每一个条目保存在一个单独的文件里，然后过一遍，把所有的脏话和亵渎词都删掉，这样他母亲就能读了。
Sergeant Horrachs sister also read the blog, and she emailed Horrachs to have him tell me to save the profanities for the movie. Honestly, I didn't even realize that I was swearing as much as I was.
Horrach中士的妹妹也读过博客，她发邮件给Horrach，让他告诉我把脏话留到拍电影的时候再用。老实说，我甚至没意识到自己骂得有那么多。
Sometimes I'd get an email that hit close to home and put everything into perspective. Like the email I received from the mother who lost a son here in Mosul several days before he was supposed to return home on R&R.
有时我会收到一封直击心底的邮件，让一切变得清晰起来。比如我收到的一封来自母亲的邮件，她在摩苏尔失去了儿子，而那是他本来预计要回国休假的前几天。
She thanked me for writing about what was going on. She said, I read many entries and felt blessed, comforted in a way, as you have given me a peek into what my son had experienced in Mosul.
她感谢我写出正在发生的事情。她说：“我读了很多条目，感到很幸运，在某种程度上得到了安慰，因为你让我窥见了我的儿子在摩苏尔经历的事情。”
You have thoughts like he would have had, I think. I just want to thank you for sharing in this way. God works through people by stirring their hearts and sometimes people never know how they're helping others. I thank you, pray for your safety, and your safe return home.
我想，你有着他本可能拥有的想法。我只想感谢你以这种方式分享。上帝通过触动人们的心来施展工作，有时人们永远不知道他们是在如何帮助他人。我感谢你，祈祷你平安，并祈祷你平安回家。
I read her email, and I sat there at the computer monitor for a moment. And I didn't know what to say. What do you say to someone who's lost a son here? I don't know if I did the right thing-- probably not-- but I never wrote her back. I didn't know what to write.
我读了她的邮件，在电脑屏幕前坐了一会儿。我不知道该说什么。你要对一个在这里失去了儿子的人说什么？我不知道我是否做了正确的事——大概没有——但我从没回信。我不知道该写什么。
Colby Buzzell. His book based on writing from his blog is called, My War: Killing Time in Iraq. We also heard from Trueman Muhrer-Irwin, who recently was tattooed with his friend, Wise's name. His foot is healed now. And Chuck Ziegenfuss. He's at Walter Reed Medical Hospital for surgeries, trying to recover feeling in his left hand after being injured by an IED. Web addresses at our website, thisamericanlife.org.
Colby Buzzell。他那本基于博客文字的书叫《我的战争：在伊拉克消磨时间》。我们还听到了Trueman Muhrer-Irwin的经历，他最近纹上了他朋友Wise的名字。他的脚现在已经愈合了。还有Chuck Ziegenfuss。他正在沃尔特·里德医疗医院接受手术，试图恢复他在简易爆炸装置攻击中受伤的左手感知。网址在我们的网站thisamericanlife.org。
Our website, where you can listen to our shows for absolutely free or do your Christmas shopping. You can buy programs on CD, Best of collections, our comic book and, especially, the DVD of the story I did with cartoonist Chris Ware. That's at www.thisamericanlife.org.
我们的网站，在那里您可以免费收听我们的节目或完成圣诞购物。您可以购买CD格式的节目、精选合集、我们的漫画书，特别是，我与漫画家Chris Ware合作制作的那个故事的DVD。网址是www.thisamericanlife.org。
You know you can download today's program in our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife.
你知道你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife的档案中下载今天的节目。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际传播。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who came by our office this morning with doughnuts-- yes, doughnuts-- and a warning.
我们节目的WBEZ管理监督者Torey Malatia先生，他今天早上带着甜甜圈——没错，甜甜圈——来我们的办公室，并带来了一个警告。
Please don't expect every white person who comes to do this.
请不要指望每个来这里的人都会这么做。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周将带着《美国生活》的更多故事回归。
Is that that show by those hipster know-it-alls who talk about how fascinating ordinary people are? [SIGH] God.
那是那群谈论普通人有多迷人的时髦知识分子主持的节目吗？[叹气] 天哪。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。